Cody Wilson grabbed the nation's
attention in 2013 when he posted a video
of himself firing the Liberator the
first fully 3d printed firearm
he's now embroiled in an ongoing lawsuit
with the State Department over whether
or not he can post the printing plans
for the Liberator on his company website
he lost his case in the Fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals after they ruled that
national security Trump's the First
Amendment right to disseminate
information in this case but Wilson is
pushing ahead on the legal front and
with a new project
the ghost gunner a do-it-yourself
milling machine that allows you to
construct an unregistered ar-15 in less
than three hours without leaving the
comfort of your own home it's available
on his website for 250 dollars and
Wilson says he's already moved thousands
of units we met up with Wilson that
defense distributed manufacturing
headquarters in Austin Texas to talk
about the ghost gunner his ongoing
lawsuit and his journey from disaffected
liberal to crypto anarchist creator of
the 3d gun as documented in his new
memoir come and take it the gun printers
guide to thinking free
the book on its most superficial level
is a recounting of how the liberator
came to be but it's also at times a kind
of beautifully written meditation on the
nature of the modern nation-state and
the position of the dissident thinker
within that state and it's also kind of
packaged as a how-to guide not how to
make a 3d gun how to be someone who
would think of creating a 3d gun when it
didn't exist before so what exactly were
you aiming for with this book well
thanks for those descriptions you
couldn't help my publisher was saying
from the very beginning we want to
manifesto manifesto and I don't want to
do it yeah I don't I wanted an excuse to
tell the story about how the livery was
made of course the narrative of the
Liberator is the excuse to take you into
these places of anti-state thought if
you will but even that even that is to
like make it a little dry it's just as
somewhat like you said in the beginning
what is it to have to think 3d printer
what is they have to think something
contrary to what is deemed to be
official knowledge or you know the
official course of things where do you
have to go what is what is the moral
trajectory required what happens to you
and what do you give up that's something
I just wanted to communicate to people
because I was not the same person at the
end of that then I was at the beginning
the beginning where this idea kind of
springs to life is you're in a hotel
seems like a hotel lobby with some
friends having a discussion about
WikiLeaks and one of your friends comes
up with the ID with the phrase wiki
weapon yeah tell me about the concept of
a wiki weapon and how that kind of
started your thought process for months
in the summer of 2012 there are only
thoughts were well we could print a gun
you know and we were just vaguely you
know familiar with and boosters of
WikiLeaks it seems obvious now to say
well WikiLeaks for guns but we weren't
thinking about in those terms for weeks
and weeks and when that finally kind of
crystallized for me I was like my god
you know we didn't have the language of
crypto Anarchy yet or the cypherpunks
yeah we didn't we didn't really know we
just we were doing something that had a
kind of vague political feeling but
didn't have a name and and when uh in
those moments WikiLeaks for guns
happened we all just kind of understood
like oh this is the mish
I know it was always going to be the
internet serving guns oh my god what a
vision and it was just like an instant
realization for us and what is the power
of wiki leaks or just kind of the wiki
concept to you
I think Internet natives guys are Asian
and younger you know when we discovered
Wikipedia for the first time you know
what that was doing the knowledge and
the collaborative Democratic production
of things from the bottom up essentially
you just understand even without again
without being able to write a
dissertation about it we understand that
the internet was doing and serving
political tides that were wholly
undesignated unsupervised and that the
internet would mean all these
politically consequential things and
that we would be a part of it so I mean
you can't it was wholly accidental and I
want to emphasize that a lot of this
book is about capturing the accidental
with the will of the political and just
kind of letting the objective army of
the universe feel your sails keeping in
that vein of this being in a in a
vertical itical act early on you say I
believe the print of pistol lays bare
Western ethical ideology what is that
ideology in your view and and how does
the pistol reveal that so I'm
specifically referencing in the sense of
bad jew ethical ideology that there's a
under guarding moral force in our
politics that's just kind of assigned or
assumed without question this is often
the ethical ideology of progress that
technological progress is good that has
a good moral force and that we do good
things when we contribute to technology
enabling the Democratic all these
assumptions are incorrect when people
say oh you know we'll be on the right
side of history or they they kind of
expect or play along with this idea that
technology has a progressive force with
history and everything is leading
towards some type of cohesive whole
this integrationist idea that history is
is eventually moving toward you know
we're all getting smarter all getting
better everything's getting better
politics is getting not as you know not
as conflicted politics now is about
totally eradicating the forces of
difference in antagonism and indeed I
would argue the essence of politics
itself we are striving toward in our in
our more
progressivism our ethical ideology we
are striving toward an age where
politics is kind of after the fact and
idea litical era where look what we're
not you know Hillary Clinton arguing
like you know borders whatever culture
whatever those are just points of
conflict we're a part of a global
integrationist whole we are stronger
together all right
this is her gayleen unionism yeah and I
would argue that that has a certain
bankrupt moral force that is just
assumed to be dominant but really can't
drive people isn't interesting so I
stand against I stand against these
ideas you've described yourself as a
crypto anarchist and I mean what is the
political point that you're hoping
decentralized distribution of weapons is
going to push forward there's both the
symbolic power to what we do that we've
always recognized and played with but
there's also I would argue a deep
political realism to what we do you know
in this in the shop we make machines
that produce ar-fifteens we sell them by
the thousands and ship them by the
thousands these go to people who can
then make literal ar-15s and military
specification there's a certain
political realism here if you have the
implements outside of federal
observation for military-grade hardware
I mean if you have that hardware it can
produce it you have certain political
capabilities that perhaps your neighbor
does not we believe in a reality of
politics at the end of the day even
though like I like to hang out
stretching the books on this boat grd
and you know kind of sphere yeah it's
all about you know how do we we SAP the
symbolic power of our enemies we operate
on both both spheres and therefore it's
somewhat schizophrenic I want to show
something with the book the fluidity of
ideology but also indeed like the
transformative necessity of him even
like the transcendent necessity of
politics I begin as a liberal I discover
the cypherpunks and crypto hierarchy and
then by the end I'm not even sure I'm an
anarchist anymore I'm I feel like I'm
almost just like the accidental node and
something else in my book something
deeper and not at all
concerned with the affairs of men one of
the kind of grounded political thinkers
he references James Harrington and like
the Republican radicals yeah and this
idea of a universal militia which really
is the basis of the Second Amendment
when you dig down to it what does that
mean
in the modern context to you so the
Second Amendment if we're being honest
yeah
comes from this neo Republican tradition
from a controversy in Republican
politics you know as a reaction to
monarchy that has nothing to do with our
current concerns right we we are
decadence we are provided for you know a
political economy as in division of
labor have seen to it that we don't
really feel the need to be our own
farmers our own soldiers and really like
whole civic beings in the way Republican
theory of the 18th and 19th century saw
that we might be the early republic of
America is gone and those Republican
radicals are having a conversation we
don't even understand but one of its
lingering effects was written into our
document and it was that all men all
freeholders would have military-grade
weapons they would form the basis of the
defensive forces of the country so that
there wouldn't be a standing army or a
mercenary force and so that we would
have a better moral economics civic
structure that would be less prone to a
kind of corruption that could create
military forces that could then overturn
the country it almost makes no sense at
all anymore and in fact all even the
good ii remember literature calls it
embarrassing or terrifying but it's here
and almost like in the work of Agamben
almost almost completely unique in
history the founders wrote in a duty to
resistance and a right to military great
hardware into the founding documents
incredible incredible to me the
government's control nuclear weapons and
other high-grade weaponry so what sense
does it make to even have everyone armed
does it does it matter if I want to put
my liberal hat on I guess a sure
government's control nuclear technology
but Azzam as the big lawsuit I have
against the State Department
demonstrates governments have never
controlled certain calibers of weapons
from their birth they've never actually
controlled the people's right to keep
him bear arms that that's an
anglo-american tradition that was always
first in the hands of the people so you
could say like well we live in a
high-tech age a post Cold War age of
really incredible technology that the
government controls from birth but
that's never been true of the firearm
perhaps the technological moment then
begins to make you question access to
the farm but it's never been easier to
make these things and it's always been
easy to make them but let me take my
liberal hat off let me go back to this
near Republican stuff I I argue I claim
that
doesn't matter what the origins in the
second amendment were with the internet
we can transform this thing into duty to
resistance on a global scale right to
resistance on a global scale and we
don't even need to use the words rights
or duty if I if it's simply a fact that
the internet serves guns now this is
just a point of political life you're
someone who runs towards the outrageous
and you know staking out a kind of a
provocative position as opposed to say
seeking middle ground and trying to find
compromise there I guess my question is
why are you such a mischief-maker
cutting middle ground man here's the
thing right what's the middle ground on
a liberty and tyranny right like you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna put them throw
the softball here right
what should I announce my my intention
to join the cabinet of Gary Johnson or
something when he wins
give me a break give me a break there's
there's no middle ground here all right
we're we're facing an overwhelming tide
of technological super statism
surveillance and control the harnessing
of the financial networks the
information flows and the subject D
subjectification I mean like of your
mind
and so no there's not enough extremity
and there's not enough mystery one of
the amazing aspects of the creation of
the Liberator is the way the role that
the media played and you go into great
detail about their reactions to what you
were doing and I mean this was it the
most nascent stage where the gun was
just an idea and you were just kind of
leaking out details about what your
ambition was and there was media freaked
out immediately rachel maddow of MSNBC
in particular was kind of your bete
noire she would constantly be mocking
you and saying this is this isn't real
yet there was a kind of nervous energy
to it all how did you view the media and
use them as a tool for your own ends I
felt actually there was always a mocking
like in incredulity I mean yeah Rachel
Maddow's one of her first comments I
remember was look at that gun not
you know like yeah it was one of these I
she would said like yeah it's a gun but
it's a crappy gun right I was like well
I'll take it right everything would they
have to color the event okay fine yeah
but there is the event and of course in
so many moments early in the project
just the idea of the event I mean it was
still a simulation it was still just
images it was still just like you know
if you only knew that terribly like
embarrassing vulnerable like physicality
of these things these objects would just
crumple and fall apart right but like
they were preserved and made so strong
in these images they were I think I
called them like these handmaidens of
the event yeah they wanted to Shepherd
didn't tell you like oh no it's you know
look it's really weak don't worry about
it it's kind of it's kind of funny
almost but it's happening and they can't
help but mark the fact that it was
happening even if in my mind at the time
it wasn't quite happening yet right
that's that's the nervous relationship
with the media and there's a kind of
irony that they helped conjure it into
reality was by being perfect afraid of
it the finer points of the meteor that
they don't wait for the actual tear of
the event to happen they jump in to the
situation and complete it themselves in
this nervous anticipation that we talked
about so take Liberty for example once
the ride was finished no one waited for
tears to bring it on the trains
journalists smuggled it onto trains and
then took the pictures and put it up on
the Daily Mail and same thing with in
Israel journalists snuck it through the
into the Israeli Parliament I mean
incredible and this is actually like
this is predicted in the in the media
theories of John baudrillard you know
they don't wait for the organic natural
event to complete itself they'll jump
into the void and make it happen so the
media cannot help themselves if I if I
can get something 80% of the way they
will take it to its completion and then
a bit further than that they can be
dependent upon to do this I can't help
but think of a particular person when
you're talking about all this the media
pushing a phenomenon into existence and
that person is Donald Trump and we're
taping this before the election yeah we
don't know yeah you know by Thomas Ayers
he'll either be President or Hillary
will be President so what do you feel
any not necessary political kinship but
he lemon is there sort of guilt or
occasion that's you Donald Trump you
know like what's your analysis of that
as someone who himself has
to the media in a way who can feel
kinship to Donald Trump but he is he is
alone in in his singularity he is I
think an innocent almost like atavistic
force right he's this almost like almost
totally childish in his complete
innocence like he is a completely honest
to whatever he is but totally
inscrutable like and that's not me
calling him like insulting him and
calling him a fool the man is a genius
and has incredible instincts and
certainly understand some of these
things about the media and in more
natural way than I ever will and many of
us ever will I can't I can't place him
no one can place him and this kind of
blindness this kind of total
reflectivity is surely what is
propelling him to almost almost
clinching the presidency though I look
at the polls today he's within the
margin of error everywhere nationally
and he's about to close in New Hampshire
here and maybe even Colorado I mean how
was he doing I don't know do I feel any
affinity I don't know I feel all like
everyone else complete all and I tip my
hat just a bit to him in the book I mean
you know I was thinking of things in the
very beginning before wiki weapon that
involved you know concrete manipulations
and going to different markets and kind
of trying to pull media I mean Donald
Trump can play every one of these games
simultaneously on every level everywhere
he found the scene he found the threat
and he's pulled it you know and at the
same time there's a huge unconscious
force that is propelling him right wing
ethno-nationalism drags it like all of
these the suppressed remainder is
returning and Donald Trump I guess is is
riding away you have some harsh words
for the so-called maker movement in this
book and it you know ostensibly you're
part of it the movement where people are
seizing the means of production for
themselves and just making things we
don't even use the word seize right a
maker would never use the word seize you
have you have to dial it back okay your
question what would be a more
appropriate verb and your makers hug the
means of production base the means of
production and so you you view them as a
kind of frivolous could you tell me what
your prob
with the self-anointed makers movement
funny that you would say like well
you're part of the maker movement mm-hmm
well I was never made to feel that way
right and I was never consciously
represented as that if anything there's
been in the beginning of our project
there was a fight with the traditional
crowd the gun control crowd the kind of
political crowd and then this other
fight with the people who were supposed
to be kind of working with the same
technology as us this total well an
extra patient really I mean purging
everything that we're doing from their
message boards administrators telling
people not to link to our content right
on the on the sub like on the cultural
level and then on a higher level that
level the masthead publications like the
magazine make magazine this level of
curating our content telling that what
we were doing was an abortion of the
principles and we really kind of mucking
it up for everybody while simultaneously
I began to realize in consumption of
their own media oh my god we are the
promise of their movement if what if
anything of what they said was true then
it was that like we were reinvest
realizing we were doing actual real
physical things yeah making like useful
objects with their technology and then
propelling those into other people's
hands who actually wanted to use them
but this this project around you right
here is perhaps the most successful
living open hardware project this is
what a Maker project should be I you can
go to conferences and where they'll
scratch each other's heads and look at
each other start each other in the face
and go you know how can we make open
hardware to work well you have to find a
good application you have to deliver
something that people that they actually
want and that's often constrained
politically there's like a superficial
political scarcity okay there's no pence
design patents utility patents copyright
and like there's nothing on these
devices these are open platforms we sell
them by the thousands and we make money
on them we propel ourselves into
lawsuits and we do Rd this is an open
hardware project and yet we are not
claimed by this movement we're not
claimed by this movement because we
openly reach for the political in the
beginning we say making means this it
doesn't mean this kind of just permanent
diversion into nostalgia this permanent
diversion into the sandbox of late
adolescents even well into your
adulthood grow out your neck beard play
Minecraft and kind of sing about how you
built something out of Legos today right
this is to be this is to be ridiculed on
this level right but you have to grab
like the importance of the urgency of
your moment right and I thought the most
harsh thing I ever said in the book
about the makers was that their revolt
was not Luciferian it was not
serious the flagship machine of the
maker movement in 2012 was called the
cupcake CNC these are serious people
right and I mean let's talk about what
you are doing here in opposition to you
know the cupcake CNC well right it's the
but to be clear right
my words are critical but I don't I
don't style us as an opposition to the
makers they do not they do not form a
part of the horizon of our ambitions
your there's simply a kind of unhappy
you know sad little thing we're talking
about the arrows and sticks that they
threw our so our soul into consequential
no I mean we run this [ __ ] man yeah but
people want to know you know what's
going on in your workshop now and you've
moved from printing plastic guns The
Liberator that's documented in the book
- metal guns you have something called
the ghost gunner could you tell us about
the ghost gunner project and what you
hope to achieve with it I want to be
clear though I mean I didn't abandon nor
did my engineers abandon our work in 3d
printing the Liberator printer is just
around the corner here in the shop okay
we got two 3d printers in this shop we
do 3d printing and I work here and we
still work with guns and I have an
off-site research and development center
for 3d printing that has the most
advanced current 3d printers we're doing
that work but there's been in the years
since Liberator this this total stop
work forced upon us by the government
now committed anarchist in the Internet
go okay well post your stuff anyway if
you're so big and bad go post it why
can't you post your stuff we believe
that we can carve out or preserve some
of what we did in the courts right now
at least we have the opportunity to and
we have the resources and the means to
we have the legal talent to and so I
built a ghost gunner this parallel
organization and company that surrounds
us now we make a milling machine we sell
a milling machine that helps you finish
ar-15 they are tens soon 1911 frames you
can have the real physical implement to
military specification in your hands you
can complete that for yourself outside
of the Federal Firearms Network that's a
real that's a real good thing for people
people like to buy that and when they
buy that they support our lawsuits so I
don't have to stand out there all day
being like oh I'm a victim help me oh
please the government wants to give me
so this project is to help us preserve
the days and in the moments and what we
thought we gained with
the vents in the book come and take it
so you see this as a kind of pre-emptive
insurance policy against gun control
because now over the ghost gunner the
ghost gunner yeah we're trying to push
through the facts on the ground that
changed what the political reality is
independent of our institutions in our
processes okay hopefully one day it
won't matter what these men and women
black robes say because you just know
that you can download the air 15 from
the internet crank one out in your
garage crank two out in your garage if
you're having a board saturday okay this
is real this is more real than any any
reagan appointee clinging to life
somewhere in new orleans who tells you
something about your technology can ever
force upon your life you know this is
reality can you tell us a little bit
about the lawsuit and and how it's
affected your work okay a couple days
after we released liberator the
government finally said okay no no this
isn't gonna this isn't gonna go and so
begin a process where we were stymied
and forced into strange processes and
boxes where we were just constantly
deferred too far deferred and you know
if you read the put the great political
philosophers of the moment all of their
theories revolve around real politics is
simply in deferral mmm-hmm all politics
is now deferral of strange forces and so
about a year into this process once my
lawyer once I stopped listening my
lawyers telling me Oh any day any day I
was really I was realizing okay this is
it it's just gonna be this permanent
deferral we will have to mount a
challenge you will have to build a team
together we will have to like build a
war chest to officially challenge this
in the language of the state in
constitutional terms bring a facial
constitutional just to be clear on the
basic facts this was from coming from
the State Department that's right
there's a bureau in the State Department
which administers the arms Export
Control Act right so this isn't DoD it's
not the army it's not ATF it's the State
Department and curiously they look at a
power foreign affairs and say well if
Americans do this and do too much of
this and speak to publicly about this it
interferes with the executive power to
administer Foreign Affairs or to be a
good executive of Foreign Affairs so
because a foreigner could download The
Liberator plans no American has the
right to download The Liberator plans
this is the literal argument in court
and it's not a difficult one if it was
about dildos if it was about birth
control if Saudi Arabia didn't want it
since to be able to download plans for
birth control on the internet do you
think I would be in court for three
years at this point we know the answer
to this question
yeah it's about guns and gun cases are
losers in this federal judiciary and
these in these appellate courts they're
losers literally the the three-judge
panel majority opinion statement the
hood the linchpin statement was you know
normally the Constitution is a very
strong protector of liberties but in
this case so yeah the government in
certain cases especially gun cases gets
to just wave around the words national
security without making a specific claim
is there not a serious concern there
that you know where when we see
something like Isis for instance where
they are extremely decentralized
movement and they inspire people over
here to go on shooting sprees that this
kind of technology is going to enable
that so there there's got to be some
sort of control over it that's the the
argument that as I understand it I think
it's a fair question for you to ask in
the nature of objectivity I just maybe I
don't consider it a serious enough
question I just look at the capital
stock of guns in this country more than
300 million now there's estimates of
four to six hundred million guns in this
country mm-hmm and then I look at that
the nations of our technology I mean
it's it's so in its earliest phase and
and then I look at how Isis actually
gets its weapons from Federal Firearms
licensees sure but through the direction
of the State Department and the CIA and
other proxies and affiliates in other
countries that are supposedly NATO
members I mean come on they're driving
this violence but there's no chance that
we could ever drive it in a comparable
and
what is it a proportionate way one thing
that I found interesting when you were
talking about that situation was your
analysis of the medicalization of
language that happened for gun control
could you tell me a little bit about
that pivot politically and what you
think that the end result of that is
gonna be this medicalized common sense
and products liability discourse of gun
control is now obvious and everywhere
but we were beginning to see it
successfully focus group in 2012 and
2013 and then in March of 2013 Sandy
Hook promise came around
Silicon Valley got behind it and
Bloomberg demonstrated that his plan now
even before mentioned to me directly
failed but his plan would be to go
state-by-state to use to use a suburban
discourse right of moms and and
synthesizing the old moms demand action
and Brady Center a rhetoric into a
rhetoric of products liability and
safety and things that are
unobjectionable when we say gun safety
now what do we mean right to flip it
into this kind of ambiguous rhetoric no
longer gun control it's gun safe dry oh
yeah and that cut that cuts against them
in some ways but in many ways it doesn't
and it propels ballot initiatives
because everything's unobjectionable the
public polling statewide is at eighty
percent we were seeing granted my book
was published only recently but of
course this was written a couple years
ago at the time it wasn't totally clear
to everyone that this was where the
discourse was going so I was in Europe
at the time explaining to people look
they've gone you know they focus group
this [ __ ] underground man they're gonna
go toward this this holy medical and
capitalization of everything they're now
going to develop personal and public
pathologies of gun ownership they're
gonna couch everything in language of
safety there was this arc that we were
beginning to understand very early in
wiki weapon that they were going to
change the flow of the language about
gun control mm-hmm yeah and I mean in
the shift towards safety at what you
call the kind of suburbanization of the
language it appeals I think particularly
to the baby boomer generation you have
some unkind words for baby boomers in
your book as well you you go on a very
entertaining rants about the pilot of
the newsroom which is this kind of
terrible ode to baby boomer values what
what's your beef with the boomers the
spoiled children of history
okay the generation that's had the
easiest time perhaps in any generation
ever will ever has and that they can
still point the finger as hard as they
do now sure Millennials are wrecked and
Generation Z even more so we almost
can't handle adversity yet but at the
same time we still have to live with a
lot of it we save more the generations
before us we have to live with a
permanent kind of underclass income
despite like our over our overweening
ambitions and that tension produces
psychological dislocations and intense
need to cultivate a individual
personality and look at a struggle right
in a ways that the baby boomers never
had to they just had to keep their asses
out of the war
you know sing oats to their parents and
spend a little prayer wheels and just
you know on one income build nuclear
families and take advantage of all that
easy all that easy credit over the years
and then ask us what the problem is when
everything's falling around [ __ ]
around us every day
stratasys a 3d printer manufacturer
repo'd your printer once word got out
that you were gonna use it to print a 3d
gun and they actually reported you to
the ATF for what you were doing
IndieGoGo took down your campaign at
some point you're basically toxic to a
PR obsessed America yet you did get
published by a corporate publisher how
did you manage that
and what's that relationship been like
were they kind of surprised at what they
had purchased yeah my troubles with
corporate America never ended and indeed
like aren't even him the ones detailed
in that book aren't even impressive
compared to the ones I've had has two
years Wow it never ends and we know
about things like operation choke point
how the banks and the merchant
processors and people consider work like
this extreme and overwhelming is the is
my relationship with corporate America
and it to the point now where I I don't
put my name on applications I don't put
my name on official you know what I mean
that correspondence another writing I
have to use other companies and other
people all credit where credit is due to
my literary agency foundry at the same
time you might expect that most of the
publishers I visited were like oh my god
no no we're not gonna do this yeah there
was no bid too many things and look I'll
go ahead and say it because I've been
working with or trying to organ for a
long time penguin the penguin group were
a bunch of right [ __ ] about it and I
mean not only were they just like no
thanks
and you could say no thanks but they
were like look this book is evil mm-hmm
it would be incorrect and wrong to poach
this book and me that's real talk so
tell me there's not gatekeeping and
publishing there certainly is but you
can break through if your heart is
headed you have your head it's hard
enough so Simon and Schuster put this
thing out I think they always wanted
kind of something more accessible but
this is what they got it's impressive
that they that they backed it and
but even so you did get a chapter or
censored there's a chapter and not not
by Simon Shuster but by the government
there's a chapter that is I'd say about
80% redacted could you tell me what
happened there in the United States of
America you can't actually publish
information related to making guns to
the public you can't do it it's illegal
now the government knows they can't
literally go scoop up all that stuff it
would be an overwhelming reaction but
I'm under a particular scrutiny by both
the defense technology security
administration and this Directorate
under the State Department that
administers the ITAR and it literally is
a crime for me to publish the things
that I published and so I thought I must
publish them and I must show you their
redaction with the ghost gunner
you are my understanding so you're able
to sell the instructions to print them
but you can't give them away for free is
that right yeah that's right
because the way I want to give my plans
away I want to put the money in it or I
want to leave them at a bookstore anyone
can come pick them up both of those are
considered illegal and by the United
States government but of course you can
sell anything in this country I can sell
a ghost gun or I can sell a ghost gun or
overseas and I can sell the ghost gunner
software to anyone who's a US citizen
with the US address any any idea or
theory of why that is true that you can
sell something but not it does give it a
like a coherent yeah idea after the Cold
War I mean you can trace the whole
history the arms Export Control Act from
the Second World War
what was first just a limited right
temporary restriction on literal Defense
articles during wartime became the
framework for an entire Cold War
thinking about technology and
technological exchange in an era where
oh it's very important that our
adversary not not acquire our technology
that it not even infiltrate our Free
University system so it became a way of
guarding and guiding how we even
exchanging knowledge in formal and
public settings we're living with the
consequences of the Cold War here these
regulations that I'm fighting haven't
been amended since 1984 officially there
there's some interim final rules but
they don't even they don't even
cognizant internet an internet you
didn't talked about so when you finally
have an Internet exploding half of these
regulations there's no way to capture it
and so they have to simply assert power
where there is none and you go fight
about it in court
get a bunch of judges who hate guns to
just kind of be like well yeah I don't
see anything wrong if people want to
support you and your project and and
what what you're all about how can they
best do that to support the workers
events distributed you can buy a ghost
gunner you can buy an eighty-percent
receiver if you want to build in the
ar-15 buy an 80% receiver a parts kit
from us you know if you want to do that
work you're supporting the work of
defense distributed our efforts in court
our research and development which goes
right back to the public if you want to
get to know more about us read the book
all right I'm selling a book read it we
come from a place of true millennial
disaffection but we believe in a reality
of politics which makes us romantics
because politics is dying
politics is evaporating wake up wake up
my god that doesn't mean you have to
vote for Trump but pay attention to
projects like ours and the crypto
anarchists support public-key encryption
support Bitcoin do everything you can to
get the hell out of here and support the
balkanization of this overwhelming power
Cody Wilson thank you very much for
talking to us thank you for reason I'm
Zach Weiss Mona